honored walk is long gene watches have
110 World's Fair grand prizes twenty
eight gold medals and more honors for
accuracy than any other time fees lon
gene the world's most honored watch is
made and guaranteed by the lawn gene
with no watch company it's time for the
launching conosco a television journal
of the important issues of the hour a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
wats company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene Cronus coat mr. Henry Hazlitt
editor of The Freeman and contributing
editor of Newsweek magazine and mr.
william bradford huie editor of the
American mercury our distinguished guest
for this evening is general Kenneth C
royal former United States Secretary of
War the opinions expressed are
necessarily those of the speaker's
general royal you were secretary of war
in 1947 when the unification program was
under discussion I was wondering what
you thought of that program now in the
light of the experience what its
shortcomings were or what its
achievements were well as long as I
remained in the defense establishment I
was convinced that unification neither
save money nor promoted efficiency and
I'm still of that impression but we
can't reverse it we've got this to try
to improve it and I believe it is being
improve
do you believe that we could improve it
by having a greater degree of
unification sir I do I think a more
complete unification a single department
and ever since would be the answer well
I'd like to ask what you think about our
spending in general now I mean not only
on the Defense Department but our
overall spending do you think that there
is a real probability within the next
year to Louisville war with Russia no I
don't think so I don't think war is
imminent in any sense that's my
impression well you think in view of
that at our general spending level is
too high for the president well it may
not be too high if we look at defense
alone but if we look at defense in light
of the nation and national economy I do
have a feeling in it is too hot you're a
Democrat of course sir and I babe you
campaign strenuously for President
Truman in 1948 now as an American
citizen and a thoughtful one are you
concerned about the fact that our
government is seems to be getting bigger
and bigger each year I am sir and I'm
worried about the financial aspects and
I'm worried about the administrative
aspects and chaperonage of the people
what do you think can be done general
royal to cut expenditure that you any
particular ideas mind on that line if
you mean can i specify certain
expenditures that I think might be
eliminated I don't believe I qualified
to give you that answer but I do feel in
general that Congress should exercise
its constitutional duty of supervising
expenditure or more closely and more
than they do today well how could they
do that what they have to have more help
for the committee's more larger
permanent staff or investigators or what
would you have in mind I think it's
probably a detail whether the committee
had it or some other agency provided it
but I do think they need considerably
more information as it is now a
department may know all the facts but
it's totally impossible for a
congressional committee under the
present circumstances to know whether
request is sound not in your concern sir
over our governments getting bigger and
bigger do you see certain danger signals
developing for instance are you
concerned over savings in the country or
life insurance policies and their value
I'm very much concerned I think one of
the essences of the capitalistic system
is the desire to earn and save and
acquire property and if you find that
the savings are being reduced in actual
value you are you are seeing the first
signs of very real danger from inflation
and excessive expenditure I think the
the government spending is one of the
main causes of the hole 0 and
specifically sir you're concerned about
thrift in our country and you think of
course that it must be encouraged and
you see signs that it's being
discouraged this correction and and
specifically one you see that the life
insurance policies are losing some of
their value other forms of savings
securities even government securities
are being depreciated other night their
actual purchasing power is a good
example of that was a war bonds sold in
the second war
isn't it people who bought war bonds in
1941 expected to make money off of them
as a matter of fact they didn't get back
what they invested did they probably not
quiet I'd like to ask you a question a
little bit off of this general and you
of your experience a secretary of war
and I'd like to ask how you feel as a
citizen do you believe in universal
military training I'll never believe in
it I believe in the draft when you need
it for national defense of the National
Preparedness but I think universal
military training goes directly against
the fundamental principles of American
freedom and while you were in the
government sir did you express your
opposition to universal military
training at all times now you've had
your a southern er of course and you've
had a great deal of experience with the
top brass of our country and you must
have reached some conclusions about our
professional military how do you think
that we have the most capable
professional military in the world sir I
do I think American military leaders of
the greatest world has ever produced and
they deserve a very large part of the
credit for winning World War two do you
think that they're there is any
potential danger in the professional
military mind specifically do you think
that we should look for presidents as a
rule among professional military man
well you said as a rule I believe yes as
a rule no I think the average military
man is adept and capable in his own work
but that he cannot consistent with his
military training acquire the broad
point of view
necessary for a good president but now
you have implied is certainly an
important exception to that sir I
naturally did and what is that exception
well I think everyone can guess the
exception is generalized now well do you
think General Eisenhower will be the
nominee of the Democrats or of the
Republican well I should certainly hope
that he'd be the Democratic nominee but
I'm afraid that if he agrees to run at
all it'll be on the Republican ticket I
do you believe that President Truman
will be the candidate at all because I
have absolutely no information you asked
to the plans of President Truman or
plans generalized now none whatsoever
but my guess would be that the question
of what a president who when were
running out with a pen lodged upon whom
the opponent would be well now where do
you think if the opponent for Senator
Taft that he would want to run I would
think so now so how about how about
Warren feel the same way or or do you
have any ideas of what I really have not
that I don't know just how one would mr.
government want to be evaluated your
southern nurseries I'm not mentioned a
moment ago although I believe you
operate in New York now if you're in
this alien country and I'd like your
opinions on what you think the South may
do in nineteen fifty two senators
Mathers last week said on this show that
he doubted that the South would vote
toward crewmen in 1952 do you share that
you well as what they call a Wall Street
lawyer I'm not really entitled to
express an opinion on it at this at this
time but I do believe that if Eisenhower
candidate that considerable number of
southern states with both foreign and be
doubtful about North Carolina it gave
Truman the fourth biggest majority in
the country last time that might be
reduced but I'm not sure it be overcome
now from what you've said sir about your
concerns as a as an American citizen
what do you think should be the
principal issue in the next campaign
well I think they're there to issues in
general one is for the foreign policy
the general foreign policy is sound and
the other is what our economy is being
adequately taken care of now on the
question of foreign policy are you one
of the administration's critics on
foreign policy or have you generally
favored the foreign policy of the
present administration well I've been
critical of some aspects of it but I
think the general approach of the
administration has been sound that is
that we must do something to build up
europe and the friendly nations and then
we must help them in providing a defense
sometime in 1949 i think it considerable
to do was kicked up by a remark that you
were alleged to have made about Japan
I'd like to ask you now whether you
believe that Japan would be a good Ally
in a war against Russia or whether if
Russia were to make a war whether we
would be able to defend
it was my view there it is now that the
chances are Japan would be a good Ally
you are you are in the government in
1947 it is it your you did you support
our Asiatic policy at that time sir well
in nineteen hundred and forty seven
hours I also until nineteen forty nine I
think you'd have to define the Asiatic
policy more clearly what about house and
hit reds well that never came in under
our department we never had any
authority or responsibility as to China
I thought our policy towards Japan was
an excellent one I see Sir well as I
understand what you've said tonight's
into our prana school audience you're an
American who's deeply concerned that
some of the things that are happening in
a country such as a getting away from
thrift and that you think that General
Eisenhower has an excellent chance of
being the next president thank you very
much for being with us tonight sir the
editorial board for this edition of the
launch in chrono scope was mr. Henry
Hazlitt and mr. william bradford chewy
our distinguished guest verse general
Kenneth C royal former United States
Secretary of War